today I want to talk about magic I want
to talk about awe and wonder and Oneness
and I want to do that with a very
special human for most he needs no
introduction an absolute icon of modern
music whose influence on culture has
been nothing short of Titanic Rick Rubin
is one of the greatest producers of all
time noted for his unique and some might
say counter-intuitive way in which he is
able to manifest the absolute best in
everyone he works with Rick is the
founder of Def Jam Records who now runs
his own label American recordings and
over the course of his storied career
has worked with a Litany of greats like
the Red Hot Chili Peppers Johnny Cash
the Beastie Boys LL Cool J Jay-Z Adele
the list goes on and on and on but the
thrust of today's conversation surrounds
the release of Rick's brand new and
completely transformative book the
creative act which is about cultivating
the innate creativity that dwells within
all of us but more than that
it's about a way of being it's about an
openness to possibility Wonder energy
and of course magic and while this is a
rare Audio Only episode recorded outside
with Rick characteristically sitting
across from me shirtless I assure you
that the contents that lay within this
conversation are nothing short of
profound and dare I say perhaps even
life-changing needless to say I can't
wait to share this conversation with you
so please hit that subscribe button and
enjoy this Illuminating exchange between
me and the truly singular brick room
yeah I started
it coming up on 10 years ago on the
North Shore of Kauai oh beautiful yeah
which is a place I know you've spent
quite a bit of time I love it yeah in a
warehouse
up there my second or third guest was
Gabby Reese incredible because they were
up there at the same time back in 2012
and
it's just been a creative Odyssey you
know over these many years and I still
love it just as much as I did on day one
it's a privilege it's a gift it's
it's just been such a fulfilling
experience gives me the opportunity to
sit down with people like yourself and
then share that wisdom with so many
people it's been really cool cool what I
found interesting in doing
um a podcast with musicians is when I
get to meet people I've never met before
and it's interesting the conversations
are interesting and
also I get to when I interview someone
who I know for a long time I've never
interviewed them before like I've
interviewed people that I've known for
30 years and I learned a tremendous
amount through the interview because you
don't really ask your friends interview
type questions right well you don't by
introducing a structure and formality it
kind of forces everybody into a presence
of mind that ordinarily we wouldn't do
on our own like I did one with my dad
and I was able to ask him questions that
I had never asked him what a great idea
I think everybody should do a podcast
with their parents or their extent and
not necessarily to share it yes but as a
document yes and also yeah for future
Generations yeah cool so we were
introduced by our mutual friend Stephen
pressfield we have lots of mutual
friends but it wasn't until the past
couple days that we actually got a
chance to meet and we've been
corresponding for how don't know over
like a year and a half yeah two years
something like that yeah I think trying
to make this happen uh and you're you
know always traveling and in distant
places and at one point you were like
look I do tons of zooms happy to do it
like let's just do it digitally I'm
super comfortable with that and I was
like no I don't that's not the
experience that I'm looking for I'm
willing to wait until everything the
universe sort of conspires to bring us
together beautiful and in my experience
that like discipline to wait always
proves to be the correct Choice as
opposed to like willing it into
happening when it doesn't feel like the
right moment like there is something
about timing and I'm really grateful
that we're doing this now and not you
know when originally maybe we were going
to do it yes and I think it'll be a
richer experience as a result beautiful
I'm in yeah man so I guess we have to be
cryptic about where we are and what's
going on but with an undisclosed
location somewhere in the world it's a
weird Fight Club thing but basically uh
we've been hanging out for the past
couple days
um getting to know each other a little
bit and I have so many questions for you
I'm fascinated by your life but really
the occasion for this conversation is
this beautiful new book that you've
written called the creative act uh which
I had uh the privilege of reading it
hasn't come out it comes out in Jan
anyway we're recording this in the
middle of the summer so I got an early
peek at it and it was great to read it
with a beginner's mind which is part of
the message of the book without having
read any reviews or having had anyone
tell me this is what it's about and this
is what it's not about and among the
many kind of fascinating you know sort
of emotions that I had in the experience
of reading the book was that
first off it defied my expectations of
what it would be and I had this uh
assumption you know I went into it even
with the beginner's mind idea like I
still formed an assumption of what this
book was going to be because there are
certain conventions that kind of come
along for the ride with people who write
a book at a certain stage of their
career so I was like oh this is going to
be somewhat of a memoir it's going to be
all these crazy stories of the bands and
the amazing artists that you've worked
with over the years and then you know
through that it will be interlaced with
takeaways or some wisdom that you've
accrued and it very much was not that it
was heavy on the wisdom part but it's
not a memoir at all it's really a
standalone
work of art a Timeless meditation on the
act of being a creative being what is
the experience of being an artist and
how to you know sort of manifest the
artist within all of us
so what was the
kind of inception of the idea to write
this book when
um
when the thought of doing a book I had
an experience where I got to work on
someone else's book about Johnny Cash an
artist I worked with the the let Robert
hilburn's book which beautiful book and
the last few chapters are about Johnny
Cash
um
the later period Johnny Cash and that's
when I got to work with him so we spent
some time together and he suggested we
listen back to the records and talk
about different song Choices and I found
through the process of helping Robert
with his book
I learned a tremendous amount that I
didn't know about my relationship with
Johnny Cash
just through I tend not to look back I'm
I'm always making something new I tend
not to listen back to any work I've made
in the past I'm just moving forward I
might you come across hearing a song in
a coffee shops like oh wow that's I
produce that it's unbelievable
um but I don't choose to listen also
because uh in the studio to get the
things to sound like they do we work on
them for such a long time that I'm good
not hearing it again you know like we've
done that I've put in my thousands of
hours yes so I'm good next
um
so in that experience of working on the
Johnny Cash book or participating in the
Johnny Cash book I understood what
working on a book could be and how it
could be about me learning something and
I thought about what could I possibly
offer I don't want to talk about myself
I'm not interested in myself but I am
interested in what happens in the studio
and so much of what happens in the
studio isn't about music it's about
um
I guess we could say their principles
although at the time that I started I
didn't know what they were I I knew that
I wanted uh
to share what happens
the choices being made in the studio how
that happens
um in a way that
someone else could use it and apply it
to their lives
and um so it took a very long time to
figure out what those things were
because at the time that they happened
originally in each case it was an
intuitive choice
so I spent seven years
thinking back both for all the projects
I've worked on in the last seven years
in real time if something would happen I
would
once something good happened I would try
to understand okay is there a principle
at play here that might be useful to
someone else and I would make notes and
then I tried to reverse engineer
decisions that I could remember from my
earliest works and all the way through
and again it's not about those works at
all those were just a portal into
what was the thought process to solve a
problem at the time and is there some
tool there that can help someone else
and if so I want to share that right so
in other words it's a canonization of
these instinctual tools that you didn't
sort of conceptualize them and bring
them into the studio it's just been a
process of them emerging over time in
the context of solving the typical type
of problems that come up yes and I would
say they were all essentially reactions
to
a problem essentially a problem and a
problem could be writer's block or the
problem could be
um a transition in a song doesn't work
or a problem could be
um there's a story to tell
through a song
that
Works in almost a coded way explain what
that means I'm not sure I get that
um I'll talk specifically I don't speak
specific in the book but I can hear I
can speak specific
[Music]
um
at the time that I was working with Run
DMC it was in the early days of hip-hop
and
no
[Music]
you have to understand what the world
was like at this point in time
hip-hop was a tiny niche
form of music
so tiny and so Niche that most people
not only did they not think it was good
music most people didn't think it was
music
I can remember being courted by uh the
head of a big record company because we
were having some success and he wanted
to you know work with us and he said
what do you attribute the success of rap
we all know it's not music and he's
being kind you know like imagine what or
just confused yeah or imagine what the
people who there were some people who
just hated it just were offended by it
um
so we were finishing Run dmc's album and
the album was done and I listened to it
and I felt like there's some one it's
missing something I don't know what it
is but it's missing something there's a
piece missing
and I had just had these experiences of
people telling me what I was working on
wasn't music and I was thinking about it
as solving a problem how do I
demonstrate
this is not so foreign
from what we're used to
and
the thought was
to find a song that was an existing
well-known song
not change it really
and have Run DMC do it true to what it
was
yet have it be a rap song
and the choice was Aerosmith's Walk This
Way and I picked it because of the
phrasing of the verses are a sentence
it's a non-melodic verse it's all about
the phrasing
and it works like a rap song same as a
rap song
and another meta layer on top of that is
that there's a break beat in hip-hop
music there are break beats which are a
little instrumental Snippets from
longer works not indicative of the big
work just a tiny snippet that if you
Loop it up
it's its own thing and in in hip-hop
world
they called it the Toys in the Attic
break which was Walk This Way but no one
who heard that break
knew who Aerosmith was or ever heard the
song All they ever heard was that drum
beat right so Daniel
yeah
I recollect like because Aerosmith has
its own amazing history of being huge in
the 70s and disappearing and them having
you know sort of personal issues and
then this incredible Renaissance in
their career was that song coming out in
addition to being the crossover event
for hip-hop that introduced this new
genre or medium of music to a much
broader audience was that the kind of
inception point for Aerosmith's
Resurgence yes
in both directions yeah it's
unbelievable so were you the one who
chose that band and that song and it was
a conscious Choice the purpose being
like that we need that crossover and
this will achieve that or was it just us
yeah crossover is not the right word
because crossover makes it sound like it
was a
commercial decision this was not a
commercial decision there's a way of
telling us this was a communication
decision of people don't understand this
I want to explain it in a way that
someone can understand it that was the
goal I want to demonstrate it right and
it I mean it had to have exceeded your
expectations of what it achieved I mean
to this day absolutely it's crazy
absolutely inside I don't know
it was a while ago yeah yeah a long time
ago
um you know your story is well told and
well documented but I think for people
who aren't familiar
um you know with who you are or just
kind of know some of the work that
you've done it would be good to recap
that a little bit but just to introduce
that idea
um most recently uh I not that recently
it was probably last year
um I watched The Beastie Boys
documentary and you know you recur in
that story
a lot of which you know your role in all
of that I already knew but one thing I
didn't know was that you were actually a
band member of the Beastie Boys at the
Inception we know about the NYU dorm
room and how that was kind of a ground
zero space and how the hip-hop community
at that time was such a small close-knit
group of people and there were only a
couple venues and it was the same people
showing up at those venues that created
this massive Global movement but you
know maybe talk a little bit about you
know how you came into this space and a
little bit about you know how you've
architected your career okay we all um
we were all punk rockers we all love
punk rock and the hip-hop wave happened
and for me I experienced The Hip Hop
wave as um
as black punk rock it was the same it
was uh it was a democratization of Music
it was taking music back to the streets
you didn't have to be a virtuoso player
you just had something to say and a
point of view uh a gripe an energy
something to brag about in the case of
hip-hop sometimes or a fantasy
and it appealed to me in the same way
that punk rock did
and the Beastie Boys were already a band
that I was not a member of and they were
a punk rock band
and I met them through friends and
um a guy named David skilkin who's a
really cool kid who's no longer with us
but a good friend of all of ours
and um
they had recorded a song before I was
involved called Cookie Puss which was a
College radio hit and it was
um
parody song rap related parody song
and they wanted to play that live and it
wasn't a song that you play as a punk
rock band he needed DJ and I was a DJ
going to NYU and I DJ'd it NYU events
and sometimes the dance interior and
clubs in New York not much more mainly
in the dorm but was a big fan of music
right dance interior pre Madonna around
the same time like Madonna would be
around and that was part of the that
world as a matter of fact the first
Beastie Boys tour
we went on tour with Madonna as her
opening act for her the Virgin tour her
first tour yeah yeah
so you hook up with these kids high
school kids yeah well I'm
one year older
I'm in college there in high school Adam
Yak was already in college he was at
Bard I was at NYU we hook up it starts
with me DJing in in the part of the set
where they don't play their instruments
and as our appetite for rap music grew
it was it ended up being all we listened
to
that side of making music took over and
I had already at this point in time
produced LL Cool J's not yet album they
were just singles at this time
and that were and uh t larocque uh
record called it's yours the very first
rap record I ever made which was like a
cult hit
um
using the techniques of that I used with
Tila rock or LL Cool J
we tried making Beastie Boys records in
that format like real rap records then
that's that's what we did right and in
that process was there a sort of
Awakening like oh this is this is what I
love about music it's being you know in
the producer seat trying to craft these
things with great artists or was it just
oh this came up and this seems cool and
just I'm jumping from one thing to
another and one thing you know your your
Universe just kind of slowly expanding a
series of events happened I remember I
had to leave the Madonna tour because I
had an ear infection from flying
and while I was home recovering I was
continuing to make records and based on
that experience and again luckily the
universe set up this system where uh
it basically told me home was the place
for me and um and I just realized I
wasn't resilient enough to be an artist
on the road didn't suit my um my
lifestyle and then in the earlier
records that I worked on with LL or the
beasties or Run DMC I would I would
write a lot I would write a lot of music
and sometimes in the case of the beat
more in the case of the Beastie Boys
write lyrics
[Music]
um
the idea of how much work I could
be involved in
if I was going to write everything it
would really limit how much I could do
so the idea and I like to I like to work
on a lot of things it's just I've really
eclectic tastes I love music and I like
to be busy
so if I had to wait until every time I
wrote something it took I remember the
first Beastie Boys album took over two
years from the time we started till we
finished not of recording every day but
until the ideas came it just took a long
time and you were heavily involved in
the writing aspect of that first record
yes
yeah yeah all of the music except for
one or two songs and
um I don't know 40 half the lyrics
something like that right I didn't know
that I didn't know that but that changed
after that album it was
it was it didn't
that life of writing it's a very time
consuming Act
and it would just limit the output and
for some reason I I don't know it always
seemed important for me to make a lot of
things I like
I like being productive
and um
so it just again it happened if not for
the ear infection it might not happen
that way it's super interesting yeah
these little
obstacles or I'm sure at the time you
were disappointed yeah right it was
unbelievable to run towards Madonna
people you know it was wild yeah
um and then with License to Ill I mean
that just I mean I vividly remember when
that record came out and you know me and
my friends had an obsessive relationship
with every song on that record
um that had to be
mind-mounting the extent to which that
became a cultural phenomenon and another
you know kind of real
Tipping Point in terms of the broadening
of hip-hop or a certain kind of genre
within hip-hop yeah I don't follow stats
or um
charts of any kind but I read the other
day that licensed ill was the first
hip-hop record to be a number one album
I didn't know that until the other day
yeah
um but it's interesting well I guess as
a producer you have to be a buffer
between the business side of music and
protecting the artists but
at the same time to the extent that
you're capable of like you try to stay
out of numbers results externalities
award shows I don't know how many
Grammys You've Won but like you've never
shown up for an award ceremony no that's
part of
the process of staying grounded in
what's important about what you do like
talk a little bit about this for me the
the success happens when we sign off on
a finished thing and say okay send it
out into the world that's the moment of
success and once that happens
on to the next yeah
um
because that's the only part I have any
participation in that's the only part I
can control everything else is based on
market conditions on stars aligning on
one of the store one of the stories uh
one of the stories we heard today in
what we were doing was uh many of the
people whose music came out on 9 11.
their music got lost and their careers
never recovered
just because it happened to come out on
9 11.
and
it's fascinating and that's out of
everyone's controls and that's again
it's it's Universal intervention we
don't know how it works but these are
all
um
one of the things we talk about in the
book is watching these occurrences
sometimes they're good sometimes they're
bad and thinking of it as riding a wave
and that the universe is pushing us in a
direction and we can ride with that
energy and like when you're surfing if
you really try to fight the wave it's
probably not going to work you know we
try to use the power of the wave
where we're almost dancing with the wave
not against the wave
and um that's that's the work of
creativity as well certain projects come
together very easily and they happen
quickly and they have a momentum to them
and others others are a real fight
and
sometimes we fight that fight and other
times we decide
is there another a path of less
resistance around this is there a better
way in
let's rethink well if it's so hard
something's up
not supposed to be so hard again it's
wildly time consuming takes a great deal
of focus takes patience
but if there are no signs that some
things
working at for a long time
that might be a time to step back step
away there's so much packed into what
you just said I mean first off it being
very counter-intuitive or
you know opposite to this notion that if
you want to be successful you just you
push you hustle you force things into
existence and that is antithetical to
the expression of great art there is a
surrender and an allowing and a shaping
and a sort of dispassionate relationship
you have to have
a non-romantic you know connection to
the result of the work uh in the book
you say the work is the work right what
is the work the work is lots of things
the work is hard but it's play it's
about sharing and it's about passion
it's about structure of course like it's
very Elusive and
difficult to pin down like when you said
like oh I just you know this book came
about because I've been doing this thing
for so long but I never really had a
formal sort of structure in my mind of
what exactly is in the process of
creating this book its own work of art
that you become more deeply connected to
like who you are and what it is exactly
that you do that makes you unique or you
know allows you to bring a certain
sensibility into the studio that can
Elevate the artist that you work with
but it is ephemeral so it's
understandable you're like I don't know
what it is yeah but I know what it's not
yes and and I don't know how to do it
that's another thing like before you
start any new project I always have a
lot of anxiety because I have no idea
what's going to happen now I have a lot
of experience that helps now but that
doesn't make it happen
takes a tremendous amount of patience to
wait for it to reveal itself and I guess
now I have the wisdom
to know this that be patient and I have
the discipline to stay with it for a
long time and I want to make that point
because we were just talking about
sometimes you have to bail
but
while you're in it for a long time there
are usually Clues they're usually and it
might be a radical course change you
could start out you have a moment
Something Beautiful happens think ah
this is what it's going to be and you
start running in that direction and then
you realize we're going in the wrong
direction right and then you have to you
know set a new course be nimble enough
to not to be able to walk away from that
even when you've invested you know some
ungodly amount of time and effort into
this Direction that's not functioning
it's something that we see often is the
um the initial moment when an idea
Springs forth that first sketch the
first demo the first very first rough
often has some
um energetic charge in it that's really
compelling and we hear many stories in
in music where
records come out and
people don't uh respond and then they go
back to oh well but it was we missed it
it was all in the demo you know we the
record screwed up and um
being aware of that's helpful because
you can just because you put more time
in like from the time you've make the
demo you may put in let's say we'd work
for a month after we've made a demo we
work on something for a month might work
on a song for a month we might realize
at the end of that month if we listen
back which is the key always checking
back see I know we're putting time in
but are we progressing right is it
different or is it better right just
because you're working on it a lot
doesn't mean that it's better and after
hearing it you know ten thousand times
you're so close to it and you become
like sort of immune to its Allure and
you think there's something wrong with
it yeah and so you tinker and then you
actually end up dismantling the whole
thing it's true yeah many just get
overdone
um
so in in cases when the demo is the best
version
luckily we recognize it and that ends up
being the version now but it takes
discipline confidence and experience to
recognize that the original GarageBand
version of it is actually better than
the highly polished studio version yes
and even if it has mistakes sometimes
you fix them sometimes you hear mistakes
you fix the mistakes and it's not as
good right you wouldn't expect that it's
drained of its energy it's strained if
it's Humanity yeah it's straight and we
don't know this is the other part we
don't know why it's good you you you
hear it there's no there are no metrics
for this
the idea that one person says my art is
better than your art it's an insane idea
it's like they're all it's always apples
and oranges it's like saying my diary
entry is better than your diary entry
it's insane
it's the things we make are are uh
a reflection of who we are in this
moment
and that's all it is it's not more than
that can go on and mean more than that
but that's not in our control and that's
not the reason to do it no and it's
something that cripples artists thinking
I have to make the greatest thing ever
made to humankind and then they
basically psych themselves out of being
able to make something good they give in
to the pressure of thinking it's more
than it is
um so one of the things we talk about in
the book is lowering the stakes where
we're not setting out to make the
greatest album of all time we're not
setting out to make the greatest song of
all time we're there to have fun in the
studio we're going to entertain each
other we're going to see if something
happens that's interesting to us
and there's no better
um
I found
luckily over the course of my life that
the things that I truly believe in
that really feel like something to me
other people resonate with I don't know
if that's the case for everybody but I
don't know of a better metric to use for
anyone than I really feel this if I
really feel it it's much better than I
think someone else might like this it's
not really from you know it's not really
me but I think someone else might like
it that's a dad it's a losing game yeah
yeah you have to make it to please
yourself absolutely and one of the
things I say in the book is the audience
comes last and the audience comes last
in service to the audience
the audience wants the best thing
they don't get the best thing while
you're trying to service them they get
the best thing when you're servicing
yourself
when you're true to who you are
and the more you can trust yourself as
an artist
in my case I've been every decision I've
made from
working in a different genre that I
started in every time every time I do
something different or new
always told not to do it I'm always told
it's a terrible idea
um so now every now you know you're on
the right track when you hear that well
I mean I just always be correct I'm not
but I know it doesn't matter what anyone
else thinks really you know I know what
I know and my job is to share what I
know that's all I can do I can't
second-guess myself well the idea that
the audience would dictate
to the artist what to do because this is
what we want is insanity right Insanity
it's the artist's job to express
themselves in a way that makes the
audience think differently or feel
something yes and the audience doesn't
necessarily know that yet yes right yes
Steve Jobs said you know famously the
consumer doesn't know what they want
until you make it yeah
Julie what would you say to somebody who
comes to you and says you know what I
find your lifestyle or the way that you
eat really aspirational but I'm too busy
I just don't have time I don't want to
be cracking open cookbooks and trying to
learn a new skill when I'm already
exhausted after a long day how do you
guide this person where should they go
the plant power meal planner is really
really such an amazing value it is under
two dollars a week and for that it gives
you this inspiration know-how and
thousands of recipes to create the
plant-based meals that you crave in your
own life so it's so amazing to be able
to log on to the plant power meal
planner and get the recipes the
ingredients the shopping list and then
the support from all of the coaches that
we have available to answer all of your
questions so join us in eating more
healthy vibrant plant plant-based meals
and to kick start our health intentions
this New Year we're offering you twenty
dollars off a one-year membership with
the code power 20 throughout the entire
month of January to learn more and to
sign up go to
meals.richroll.com again that's promo
code power 20 for 20 off at meals dot
richroll.com
[Laughter]
so talk about the making I think there
might be some confusion about what it is
that you exactly do like oh you're the
producer well what is a music producer
oh you go in you have this amazing taste
and when the artist is going in a wrong
direction you say no it's better like
this and you kind of impose your opinion
in a certain direction like place a a
script or a format on top of the whole
thing and like drive it to completion
and ultimately Commercial Success yes
that is nothing
at all yeah that is not at all what I do
there are many producers who work like
that I don't really know the details
because I've not watched other producers
work but I know that everyone has their
own style some producers today are
people who make beats and they're
producing a record and then when you
hear on the what you hear on the radio
or streaming is uh something that they
made the beat they gave it to an artist
they never met the artist then the
artist puts the song the words on top
and then that comes out and they're the
producer of the song right and there's
nothing wrong with that not at all I
know I remember like that's how Madonna
always continue to innovate and keep
what she was doing fresh because she
would work with these different
producers yes who had a certain sound or
a way of working with music that was
different from what she had been doing
historically yes and when I first
started I had a sound but very quickly
and just my tastes are too eclectic it's
like I would never do the same thing for
too long
um I will say there there tends to be a
thread that runs through my work
um not always but I like to think of it
as getting to the essential
heart of what's there so
um
whereas it would be like the opposite
Phil Spector was famous for the wall of
sound right a lot of sounds all put on
top of each other to the point where you
couldn't tell what anything was it was
just the wall of sound
I'm the opposite in that I want the
least amount of information
the most space
whatever you do here I want you to be
able to hear well and hear its
personality almost like
a conversation between two or three
voices
more than a wall of sound
you build the songs and then you have to
strip them down to see if it holds up
right it's about like the paring down
like what is the truest essence of this
thing and then we can add things if we
think it's improving it but like let's
take it down to the studs and see what
we're actually dealing with yeah I like
to get to like an architectural
framework of something
and experience it that way and I will
say more often than not although not
always
it tends to stay very close to that the
minimalist version
um
but I would imagine it brings Clarity
like now you know what you're dealing
with right like we're all on the same
page when it's at its Bare Bones this is
what we have yeah then we can have a
discussion about whether we need to add
anything to it or not it also puts a
tremendous amount of pressure on those
individual elements when you can really
hear them I can remember one one
successful record producer saying to me
very successful record producer saying
like I don't know how you
have the patience to make
music with so few elements because for
that to work
everything has to be perfect in in his
case he would just layer things on top
until a big thing happened that he liked
and again that's fine there's no the
beauty of all of this there's no right
way we all find our own way and if I
worked with an artist where the best
version of it was a heavily layered
dense work I'd be fine to do that I'm
I'm open to wherever it goes I'm
um
when I say the minimalist tends to
happen often that's probably where my
taste lies
but my taste in relation to whatever the
thing is that I'm dealing with and
sometimes the thing that we're dealing
with
the whole point of it is its density
so I maybe right minimal would undermine
what that is
in service of the highest expression of
the artist of itself yes that's the
ultimate parameter right like that's
what you're obviously always driving
towards
um but to just kind of extend that
thought of minimalism a little bit like
in reading the book I mean the book's
long it's like
432 pages I think at least the
manuscript I read right and uh you know
it is like this you know I Ching sort of
uh devotional piece on a way of being
right and even though it's long and I
read it in like one and a half sittings
which is not the way you're supposed to
consume this book this is a book that
should be consumed with patience and
consideration it's a book that you can
put down and pick back up and reread Etc
it felt very minimal is the point that
I'm trying to make like it didn't feel
like there was any extraneous sentences
like it is distilled down to
um you know a very specific
point that you're trying to make even
the very few stories that you use to
illustrate some of these points are like
two sentences long and like no names are
used and then you move on yeah it's not
about that I was thinking about that
early on and and um
I think if the information had the name
of an artist attached to it when you
read it you would visualize that artist
and it would be harder to put yourself
in the place because your association
with that artist would bring some
baggage into your opinion on the point
that you're trying to make yes it
couldn't help it it would sensationalize
it in a way that would undermine the
information and this was about the
information and the ability for the
information to help someone else it
wasn't about to um
talk about a past Glory right in any way
there's a lot of shared DNA with this
book and the way that you think about
creativity and the expression of art
with the work that Stephen pressfield
does in His Marvelous books like this
book that you've written is very much a
piece with the war of Art and turning
pro like these things should be read in
tandem or on the bookshelf together yes
but I think one distinction between
these two things is you have a broader
Embrace of the mystical like the Act of
Creation is an act of magic it requires
playing with energies and and really
considering the Unseen as very real like
these are tangible forces that you have
to channel and reckon with if you are
gonna be in this space of creation right
so talk a little bit about like how that
came to be part of your sensibility and
so important in the work that you do
I'll start by saying I'm a Believer and
I'm a Believer in everything I start
with the idea that I believe everything
and I'm willing to try things
the in some cases the more
uh edgy
the more interesting they are to me I'm
less interested in what the Orthodoxy
thinks I'm more interested in what the
fringes think I live on the fringes
and uh
you know I'll try I I won't take any
pharmaceutical drugs but I'll take all
kinds of crazy biohacking stuff yeah
um that's yeah that's my Mo and I and I
see
you know and I've had mystical
experiences in my life
um non-drug related mystical experiences
in my life so I can't discount these
things that happen
um will you share one of those mystical
experiences
think of a good one
okay
um
I've suffered with depression at
different times in my life starting it
started when I was 33 years old which
was the year they got Jesus turns out
but I before then I was great and then
at 33 I got hit with this uh
first a panic attack which I didn't know
what it was but I thought I was dying
and then
um and then I had serious depression for
probably
two years and at which point it was hard
to get out of bed if I even did get out
of bed
um I would see a different therapist or
healer every day sometimes two a day
at least five days a week
um looking for healing just every day
was just like this maybe this
appointment's the one that's gonna you
know we're gonna find out what's
happening and would drag myself from
healer to healer
and um nothing worked and then a friend
of mine had taken Prozac and it changed
his life and he said
not only do you say you ought to try
this but he said I will never not take
this like this changed my life this is
the greatest thing that ever happened
and while our personalities were very
different
after two years of pain it was a um
it was at least something to consider
but it was a a barrier that I wasn't
comfortable Crossing you know I was a
vegan I didn't use any medical you know
I'm really
a a person who lives in a natural way
yeah
anything any any uh interference with
that absolutely anything that undermines
nature I'm wary of
and um
I finally there was a woman who wrote a
book who was a
she was a psychic
and she was a psychopharmacologist
and I thought okay if I'm ever gonna
take
a substance
I'll take it from a psychic
that I'll do that yeah okay
so I went to see her name was Judith
orloff and I went CD with arloth told
her what was going on told her the story
about my friend in the Prozac
and she said
it's certainly worth trying and she
prescribed it and told me what to do
take it take it right before you go to
sleep
and um and I took it that first night
and
I woke up an hour later
Wide Awake
feeling
energy racing through my body as if
there was a race going on in my body it
was the worst feeling the worst feeling
she also said when you take this you're
not going to feel anything for six weeks
you know take six weeks to start working
right titrate up or whatever so I took
it first night hour later wake up bad
and I'm just laying in bed scared until
the morning
Wide Awake terrified that I'm dying
until I can call her and find out what
to do and finally eight o'clock in the
morning I get through and she says okay
don't take that one again
so that was it was a bad start
and then um I ended up trying many
different antidepressants one after
another every one of them made me sick
right away
um
the ones that didn't make me sick
I waited the six weeks taking them every
day and didn't work
so no nothing worked and then finally
One Drug worked and it worked again
not like I was told it would work I was
told you know well wait six weeks see
what happens with this drug I took it
the first evening
and it felt like
within a half hour
all of the light in the room turned to
candlelight and I was being held
embraced in a safe hug
and that night I felt better for the
first time in those two years
and um and a side effect of that
particular drug
is that you gain weight nobody told me
that but I was on the drug for six
months eight months and I gained
something like 70 pounds and I was
already overweight mm-hmm
um it's interesting also that the I
don't I've never really researched this
but the fact that the one drug of all
the drugs that I tried that worked for
me I already had a weight problem
also somehow
side effect made me gain weight
makes me think my weight and depression
somehow are related I don't know I don't
know enough about science of that but it
seems clear there's some connection
there too close
um so I gained a lot of weight I got
better I weaned off the drug
I was good again and the mystical piece
was in the throes of the depression one
of the things that would help me
I would drive to Malibu I lived in town
at the time I would drive to Malibu
and we had a little house a tiny little
Shack on the beach and that I was
renting and I would sit in that house
and usually I would get some
some of the heaviness would lift
so one day I went to Malibu
I got there at around noon
didn't nothing nothing listen to
classical music relax meditate meditated
for hours did all the things that would
like help get me out
and nothing got me out and I was
devastated
and and I was hopeless and in that
moment of hopelessness I prayed
and I prayed for
sign
please
Universe please give me a sign please
give me a sign to go on
because I don't think I can go on
please give me a sign
and I walked out to the beach which was
something I never did
or rarely did I walked out to the beach
and I'm standing out on the beach and in
one minute
the entire Sky turned into the most
dramatic
Orange
wild biblical painting
I've never seen anything like it up till
that moment never seen anything like it
since I walk out I experience that
it blows my mind
I feel like my answer is I I'm I'm I'm
being spoken to uh
and then within a minute gone back to
normal Blue Sky
so that was and for me that was a
mystical event right so what do you make
of that like how did that
color your sort of sense of you know
Energy's unseen
it felt like I'm not I felt less alone I
felt like I could
um
My Cry for Help Was Heard
and I felt connected and I felt really
good
in the book you referred to you talk
about the universe and you talk about
source
Stephen pressfield calls it the muse
this is the you know place from which we
can extract those
those Inspirations those ideas and
channel them through the artist into
creating something that lives and
breathes in the world but
I guess I'm curious as is Stephen
pressfield because he asked me to ask
you this question like how do you
differentiate how he thinks about it
EG The Muse versus like how you're
thinking about it as Source are those
things synonymous my sense is that
you're you have a more kind of expansive
spiritual version of The Muse maybe and
I think it doesn't matter
it's helpful to know
that the information we need
doesn't all come from inside of us might
not come maybe none of it comes from
inside of us maybe it all comes from
outside of us
and whether that be mystical or whether
that be physical whether that be
practical
I've had experiences where I'm
looking for an answer for something
curious
and I'm holding it lightly in my
Consciousness not working on it just I
know there's this problem to be solved
and then I'll be out and something will
happen in the world directly related to
answer the question it happens all the
time it doesn't happen
once in a while it happens all the time
I believe it happens all the time for
everyone
if they're paying attention if you're
open to the communication we're getting
information all the time
there's so much more information coming
at us than we can digest that we pick
and choose unconsciously
certain data points and then based on
those data points we make up story about
what happens
it's different for everybody
there's so much uh wisdom
all around us all of the time coming in
the form of nature coming in the form of
the culture coming in the form of people
speaking at a coffee shop
you know overhearing the conversation
if you're open and if you're paying
attention and I would even go further to
say I mean it probably works either way
but I would say and if you invite it it
might work even better I don't know if
that's true but why not that that's the
thing but if you're inviting it then
you're sort of injecting
a level of intention into the practice
of paying attention and being open yes
and because of the subtle nature of the
information that we're looking for it's
not getting shouted at us it's the thing
that if you weren't really quiet and
really paying attention you would likely
miss
so we have to quiet ourselves
and we have to live in a way that's why
the subtitle of the book is a way of
being is we live in the world in this
constant state of
looking for Clues looking for
information what can I learn what shapes
align where are their connections
what's more to be seen in the picture
than just the face value if I look
deeper what's happening
and um that's the practice yeah and
there are some suggestions of things
that you can do to get there but
meditation is a key for me meditation is
a key it may not be everyone's that's
the other point of this is we all
function in different ways we speak
about diet from when I was vegan right I
was wildly overweight and sick and that
was part of my depression and when you
became a vegan you became a world-class
Ultra Runner so it's like it works
different for different people we each
have to find what works for us and um
and try things and see what works which
is its own form of openness absolutely
being able to accept people in a
non-judgmental way leading with
curiosity with patients all of these
principles which we'll get into that are
kind of splayed out over the course of
the many pages of your book but on this
idea of being open I mean certainly in
my own life
the best decisions that I've ever made
the most important decisions and the
reason that I've even sitting here today
is a result of a few brief sort of
Windows of opportunity where I was
present enough to notice a whisper
and
respect it
and take action on it and I do believe
like yourself that we're all visited
with these moments
but we have to be in a place of
receiving right like receiving is a huge
theme of the work that you do and and
you know it resonates throughout the
book like how can we be better receivers
how can we attune our antennae to be in
receipt of the messages that are
available to us and you talk in the book
about the idea of it's sort of a a hive
mind Collective Consciousness notion
that ideas are real things that exist
among all of us and when our antenna is
properly attuned we can draw that down
and then the artist can translate that
into something real yes but
if the artist or anyone who's receiving
that doesn't heat it doesn't respect it
doesn't fertilize that seed the seed
being you know another big aspect of the
book it will ultimately be fertilized by
somebody else probably if not
simultaneously in time proximity it's an
idea sorry let me just finish this one
thought and we were talking about this
the other day bad idea you're talking
about this idea but I also read this
same notion in Elizabeth Gilbert's book
big magic like she talks about it in a
very similar way beautiful I haven't
read that I'd like to read that I think
you would like that book I'll check it
out it's the idea of movements when
movements happen in the art world
movements don't happen where one person
discovers something and a bunch of
people copy it it's
there was a time for abstraction for
abstract expressionism
in most art movements it's difficult to
pinpoint who was first because usually
it Springs up in groups and it might
even spring up in different places in
the world at the same time punk rock
happened all over the world at the same
time it wasn't because one punk rock
band influenced everyone else it was a
reaction to what had come before it was
time
to take music out of the conservatory
and bring it back to a street level
that's what that was about and Hip-Hop
was the same out of the uh the r b
suits and down to the b-boy mentality of
people that you might recognize on the
street how your friends might dress yeah
pre-internet by the way absolutely
before ideas could spread
instantaneously across the world
absolutely at the time that I went to
high school I was a punk rocker there
were no other punk rockers in my high
school I didn't know any punk rockers
so it was
I just think had the internet been
around when I was a kid I would have had
friends all over the world with similar
interests I had none I had none and you
had to find your people yeah or I would
go to a show and there were just a
couple of clubs yeah you could go and
once in a while you know there would be
a show once a month and yeah and there'd
be 20 people and those would be and you
might meet you know you might meet two
of them
yeah on that idea of being open
I think what's important about that is
the notion of
creativity itself and how we kind of
culturally think about it like there is
this idea that there are artists and
there are normal people I was talking to
somebody the other day and he said I
don't have a creative bone of my body
very successful person by the way
of course that's not true we're all
innately creative now most people
however kind of you were talking about
like the stories we tell how we extract
tiny little nuggets of the billions of
pieces of information that were being
exposed to on a second by second basis
and we create a narrative out of that
and I think we get calcified around what
reality is and like who we are and what
we're doing and what this means and what
that doesn't mean we walk around with
blinders right we've made decisions
about what's important to pay attention
to and what isn't so we don't notice
things that somebody who is
natively more sensitive or somebody who
has cultivated the practice of being
more open can see like we're sitting
here I have an idea of like where we are
and all of that kind of thing but
a more sensitive person sitting here
might be paying attention to something I
don't even notice because they're
attuned that way naturally or they have
developed a practice of expanding their
awareness so they're allowing more in so
talk about this idea like disabuse us of
this idea that creativity is the genetic
gift of the few and they walk the earth
differently from the rest of us as
somebody who's worked with so many
brilliantly talented people we make
creative Choice all of us make creative
choices
every day of Our Lives the way the when
we choose to take a new route on a that
we've we've driven the same route every
day and we try we decide to take the
scenic route that's a creative choice
and if we're paying attention and we
decide today I'm going to take the
scenic route and if you happen to notice
something that day on the scenic route
that you didn't notice before and that
ends up helping you in the thing that
you're working on maybe it's a
coincidence but when you come to expect
it to happen it happens all the time
all the time you know be prepared to be
awestruck and surprised on a regular
basis by things that you would never
imagine happening it happens all the
time isn't that a better more fun way to
live it's incredible and you feel like
also you feel like you're part of this
bigger thing you know I can't remember
exactly how I said it in the book but we
think of ourselves as the conductor but
we're not the conductor we're an
orchestra member being conducted
and we're part of this bigger thing
that's going on and it works like uh
like clockwork and we all play A Part
every one of us plays part and we all
have our part to play so when someone
says I'm not artistic or I'm not good at
Art it'd be like saying I'm not a good
Monk
there is no such thing as not a good
monk you're either living your life as a
monk or you're not living your life as a
monk monks aren't good or bad you're
either doing a monk or you're not doing
a monk
and we all live as artists but we don't
know it and there are things we can do
to amplify
the artistic side of ourselves that will
make everything we do
better everything any at your your
relationships your ability to
communicate your ability to listen your
joy of Life your feeling of connection
your ability to commune with nature will
it's like taking off blinders and a
problem solve we were talking the other
day and and you were like
I don't like softball questions I don't
know how to just talk about what it is
that I do like I know how to solve
problems right
to bring an artistic sensibility into a
problem-solving context
is a process of undoing everything you
think you know trying to uh you know
ditch whatever baggage and biases that
you are loaded up with and approach it
with a beginner's mind so that you can
see it more expansively and I think
obviously it's been very effective in
how you extract the best out of the
musicians that you work with but
I can't help but think about the
applications in the real world to some
of the biggest problems we have whether
it's climate change or artificial
intelligence or you know the things that
that we're grappling with that very
smart people are trying to come up with
new ideas around like we need that
sensibility as a major part of that
conversation we can't solve these
massive problems on logic and reason
alone we need inspiration we need kind
of new orthogonal approaches
that maybe we're not seeing and there's
a really great
story in the book about an AI that kind
of illustrates that point would you like
being yeah yeah tell that story uh I I
saw a video about seven years ago
about alphago which was a
AI system
created to play the game go
and they chose go because up until this
point chess had been used computer chess
but go is the most difficult or it has
the most
potential combinations of any game and
it's the most difficult would be the
most difficult game for a computer to be
able to play be good at
yeah there's like hundreds of billions
of permutations yes they're more more
permutations than there are grains of
sand on the planet that's how many
permutations so it's it's a very
difficult Computing problem
and humans have been playing the game
for three thousand years it's a very old
game
and there was there came a point in the
movie where
the computer is playing the world's
Grand Master
and
eventually the computer makes a move
that
has never been made before
it's a funny thing to say because it's a
game where you place a stone on a square
you can place it on any Square you want
you know there's no rule where you where
you kind of can't place it if you place
it on one of the one of the
intersections of the squares you can
place a stone on any intersection that
doesn't have a stone on it
and the computer made a move
that was
outside of the
strategy understanding of human beings
it placed a stone in the as I remember
it there were two choices based on the
conditions for the computer to make a
move and to even make it was either
going to place a stone on the
first line or the second line and if
they placed the stone on the first line
it meant a defensive game and if they
placed it on the second line it was a
defensive game but anyone with
experience who's playing the game ago
would know it's one of those two moves
right and those are the only two moves
that any rational person would make
anyone yes and the computer
put the stone on line three now there's
no rule saying you can't put it on line
three but it it was outside of the
imagination
of the culture of go for three thousand
years it made a move that was
I'll say irrational
to the human go world right the
community of go Wizards yes yeah and it
was so inflammatory
that the Grand Master got up from the
table in disgust
and there were some questions with the
commentators because this was this was
on on television this is a like a the
computer versus Man big story
people thought the computer made a
mistake it was like it was such a wrong
move couldn't be
and the computer ends up winning that
game the Grand Master eventually comes
back after he composes himself and the
computer wins the game
and the Grand Master ends up retiring
because his mind is so blown by what
happened right
and when I'm watching the story I
realize there are tears running down my
face and I'm crying
and I wasn't sure why
and I thought about it for a while
and it wasn't the most obvious answer
was
the computer beat the man
oh no it's the end of the world uh man
loses to the computer I'm crying because
we're but it wasn't that at all what it
was was the reason I realized the reason
the computer won
was because the computer
didn't know more than the human the
computer knew less than the human
the computer
only knew the rules of the game it
didn't know the Customs the morals the
mores
the stories
what one Grand Master learns from
another grand master the cultural
references over the years of the game
didn't know the history the etiquette
didn't know any of that all it knew was
I could put it anywhere by putting it
here it's going to increase my chances
of winning mathematically so the
computer solved a problem not by knowing
more but by knowing less
and
that's a really beautiful idea for me
because I it gets back to The Beginner's
mind idea it's not that we need to
necessarily learn more
it's more like we need to think
different like maybe if we can let go of
some of our beliefs if we can let go of
some of the stories that we hold if we
watch an event happen
instead of accepting the first version
of the story that comes to us to help us
survive in the world that's what we do
we'll we'll see a series of events
and we make up a story that explains
what that is and that way we can sleep
at night right because really we don't
know anything we don't know anything
that's the powerful Epiphany in the
whole thing this humility to embrace the
idea that we really
don't know that much and when you look
at the web telescope images it's so
awe-inspiring and it's such a healthy
dose of humility to that point right we
walk around rational beings it's the Age
of Reason and Enlightenment
we have answered many questions and to
the questions that we don't yet have
answers to we feel we're capable of
answering those very soon and yet that
is still such an incredibly Limited
perspective on the totality of what
we're actually [ __ ] contending with
which is beyond our ability as these
tiny organisms to comprehend
it's true yeah so to walk the earth with
that sensibility of actually we don't
really know anything we don't really
know anything and and when something
happens to say oh that it might be that
maybe it's that uh-huh or
let's see if we can come up with another
reason what else could it be and like
not assuming things are as they seem on
their face
sometimes they are sometimes they're not
or thinking I can think of so many times
over the course of my life where
I thought that someone was mad at me or
I thought that like I thought I knew it
was in someone else's head
and it was never true
it was only just self-negative self-talk
or some misunder something that I
misunderstood or that causes our own
suffering
absolutely so much of the difficulty is
self-inflicted and the more we can let
go of
all of our beliefs and just experience
what happens and
see what works try things it's like that
works and not to assume well that works
so that's the only way no that works and
maybe there's a hundred other ways so
what would be an example of taking that
notion into the studio like is there a
situation in which you consciously
thought
you know let's take a tip from alphago
and try to unlearn what we think we know
about what we're doing here and approach
it from the other side
uh the first thing that comes to mind
and I don't even know if we've done this
but the first thing that comes to mind
when you say that is
to ask a musician a great musician most
of the people I get to work with are
really talented
to try playing on an instrument that
they're not familiar with that would be
an example of like let's let go of all
of your practice and everything that we
think of what makes you great at what
you do you're the wizard on this
instrument
let's play something else that you never
played before and see what happens and
let's see where that goes let's see if
we find something new Shake It Up who
knows I don't know if this story is
apocryphal but isn't that what occurred
with the talking heads with naive Melody
like every member of the band played an
instrument that they didn't play I
didn't know that and that is how that
song came together which ends up being
one of their if not the you know best
song they ever created beautiful I
didn't know it might not be true but
I've heard that I've heard that story
yeah a story on the other side that's
why it's called naive Melody yeah like
the naivete of it is what created the
beauty
funny that Van Halen's biggest hit at
the time and Eddie Van Halen's one of
the greatest guitar players of all time
and song Jump was maybe the first song
he ever just played a keyboard on and
that was their biggest hit and he was
the you know greatest guitar player of
the century for some
yet the song that worked was the one
where he played the keyboard yeah
so in this idea of the creation of Art
and creativity is as a way of being
there's this quote it's near the
beginning of the book if memory serves
me this quote by Robert Henry who was a
painter and he says the role of the
artist isn't to make art but to be in
that wonderful state which makes art
inevitable so it's about creating an
environment like
acculturing a mindset a way of walking
the planet such that you're conducive
to the messages and the material
execution of the inspiration and the
ideas and that's really kind of the role
that you serve like how can you be a
facilitator of enhancing the container
of creation right and it's it's a guru
role it's a coach role it's a teacher
role and it requires a certain delicate
touch right like you have to be
patient like when the the other the
record producer or executive said to you
like I don't know how you could be so
patient like you have to be patient in
order and you have to listen and
marinate in all of this stuff and just
gently guide the sensitive soul to that
Landing place so the highest you know
expression can emerge
and to do it with as little
um
I try to do it with as little of a
footprint as possible so uh in some
cases I'm more involved in some cases
I'm less involved but I'm only as
involved as I need to be if there was a
way to make it happen
where I mean in in a dream scenario
if I could
produce an artist support them in doing
their best work without ever meeting or
speaking to them that would be the
highest form of it I've not achieved
that lovely but that would be the the
ultimate version of it just the shadow
just happened in the background it just
happened what happens though I'm sure
this happens you're in the studio you're
working it out play back something that
you just laid down and the artist says
well what do you think Rick
if your job is not to inject your own
sensibility into it
do you have to mirror that back to the
artist or like how do you kind of
gracefully dance around that my job is
to mirror my true reflection as it's
needed so in that case if if I'm asked
what I think I will absolutely say what
I think good or bad
I'll say it in a way where it's uh not
confrontational or not unkind but we're
talking about
um something outside of ourselves I
would never say it about the person it's
never about the person that's if someone
takes criticism personally
the game is over
and it's helpful to
remove whatever it is that we're making
from the people making it we're making
this thing
it's a reflection of us but it's not us
it's this thing out here
and once we have this thing out here we
could talk about this thing it's not
dangerous to talk about this thing
because I'm pointing at right now I'm
pointing at the table I'm not pointing
it rich
so it's like I'm not I'm not saying
you're no good I'm saying this aspect of
this thing maybe there's a way to do
this part better this part's good this
part maybe can be better let's see you
have any ideas how would we make this
part better can it be better
it's powerful to you know restrict that
feedback to the work taking the
personality out of it so that it's
purely focused on the common goal of
making the thing great right like it's
not a commentary or a referendum on the
human being never otherwise you're dead
in the water yes it can't be and that's
applicable in life you know
it's really interesting to sort of be a
fly on the wall for like a note session
with people who really know what they're
doing and you can see it's its own art
form right to do it properly and it
takes a lot of you know it's a soft
touch takes Grace it takes
um experience to do it well and it
requires that the ego has to vanish
right all egos have to be set aside
we're in unison as a team to create this
great thing our only interest is in
making the best thing possible credit
all of that who cares about that and
there's a maturity that's required for
that right but it's cool there's a um
you know the comedian Mike Birbiglia
he's great stand-up comedian he has a
podcast called working it out and what
he does is
help bring people on other comedians
writers actors people who are artistic
in some way and they each share what
they're working on and they sh and then
they give each other feedback on the
podcast which I think is
such a service to people to hear people
who are who really care about craft
and know how to communicate what's good
what isn't working
Etc in a really constructive healthy way
because it's so applicable to all other
areas of our life if you're having an
argument with your
spouse your partner if you're having a
conflict at work like all of these
skills have high high applicability in
all areas of life absolutely and taking
the ego out of all of it is such a key
component of
allowing the thing to be the best thing
it can be if it's about you it's about
you it's not about it and it's not about
it being its best whatever that is
whatever that is or to in any way be
defensive
when someone's sharing information when
someone gives criticism
that's how they see it
it's helpful it's it's helpful to you to
know you don't have to see what they see
but it's helpful to know that that's
what they see and the fact that it's
different than what you see that's good
for you to know that's not mad for you
to know that's helpful information right
but our our insecurities end up hearing
you're an untalented hack you're a
terrible person you don't know what
you're doing you truly are the Imposter
that you believe yourself to be like we
create these narratives out of you know
out of that in a way that ends up being
destructive and I would suspect I'm
interested in in your thoughts on this
that the most generative artists are the
ones who understand how to remove the
ego and receive the feedback for the
best interest of the project absolutely
and it's something for someone who's
never had
helpful criticism before it can be
shocking I can remember one artist very
successful artist I was um
listening to some new songs that they
were playing me and um and I gave you
know very analytical everything that I
felt on every song as they you know done
this one I felt this this this on this
one I felt this this this and I finish
and it's completely analytical talking
about the craft just this the specifics
of these things
and he said have you ever talked to an
artist like this before I started every
day it's my job he's like no one's ever
talked to me like this before
I said well I'm I'm here in service to
you I'm here to help these are the
things that resonated with me these are
the things that didn't
this is information to help you
and we ended up working really well
together after that but there was it's
initial like wow no one's ever told me
anything before right no one's ever
shared what they especially with people
who are successful people who are
successful used to hearing yes yes yes
everything's great and it's not helpful
right it's not helpful it's helpful to
have
yes yes yes when it is yes yes yes and
hmm
is that as good as it could be when is
that as good as it can be having some
sense of reality otherwise there's no
grounding they're operating in a vacuum
and they lose perspective with what's
really happening if they have no no
ability to get feed real feedback
humbling yourself to be a Craftsman
among Craftsmen right beautiful in
service well said to the higher purpose
of the work absolutely
so in this idea of a
the stories we tell ourselves about who
we are and what we're capable of and how
the means by which we communicate with
others the assumptions we make about how
those Communications are received
I think we need a new perspective on how
to shift how we think about that or to
dislodge our entrenched thinking about
how we see ourselves and how others see
us and this idea is Illustrated
beautifully by this psychological
experiment that we were talking about
the other day so I think it would be
cool to kind of even though we are
ending a little bit shorter than I
wanted to like it will give people
something to ponder and consider until
we meet again because we're going to
have to do a part two great dude all
right uh let's close our eyes if unless
you're driving
close your eyes and envision a desert
a desert
once you have pictured the desert
in the desert there is a cube
a cube
visualize the cube in the desert
there is also a ladder
see the latter
there are flowers in the desert
notice the flowers
there's a horse in the desert
picture the horse
and finally there is a storm
what's interesting about this experiment
is if you were to you might even want to
write down the details of your of what
you're imagining
and
the next time you're with a friend or
loved one
ask them to do the same
you can either play this for them or
read them the cues the six cues
and then compare
your
Cube image story
and their Cube image story and see how
similar or different they are
try with your friends since an old it's
an old I first did this about 20 years
ago and I remember
um the first time I did it
having a very clear vision of what my
my story was when that when I was given
those cues very simple cues
and I imagine that's what it looked like
and then I spoke to some other people
around the table who took the same
answered the same questions and
it was mind-blowing how different our
pictures were
and
it's a great example of
how
we all imagine such different worlds
and it's why
if we don't make the thing we want to
make
if someone else's antenna is more tuned
to ours
and they pick up the same Source
material
the thing they make it's not going to be
the same thing we would make no one can
do our part
our picture is our picture so
there's a great benefit in taking a risk
making the thing that's interesting to
you
sharing it with the world because if you
don't do it nobody else will you're the
only one who can make the art that you
can make
and it's not in competition with anyone
else there is no competition there's no
competition who has a better picture in
their head
it's a reflection of you everything that
you make is a reflection of who you are
and
how you live in the world will impact
the things that you make and I wish the
best of luck on the journey in making
beautiful things that we can all enjoy
yeah it's beautifully put I think a
fantastic way to end this this call to
action that we all have something inside
of us that is worthy of exploration and
expression because there is no other you
and that in and of itself makes you
infinitely valuable absolutely and
you're depriving all of us of that if
you choose not to
share true and if you want to know the
psychological meanings of your Cube you
can Google Cube psychology test and I'm
sure you'll find the uh
what everything means if you're
interested yeah cool do that then pick
up the creative act it really is a
beautiful expression if you want to more
finely attune your radar to the subtle
art of making things and adopting a
certain way of being I can't think of
any better way to to start there I mean
it's
it's really something special so thank
you for writing it and I think people
are gonna
really enjoy it beautiful thank you for
speaking to me and thank you so much for
reading it yeah I hope that I can call
you friend and again I would like to
have you back so if we ever find
ourselves even though we we kind of live
close to each other you you're in Parts
Unknown so I had to grab this
opportunity we have background noise and
all of that but it's an organic living
breathing thing beautiful you know I
love it and when we hear it back we'll
remember where we are and what's
happening it's beautiful for sure
forever cool thank you sir thank you
[Music]